now my personal encounter was with the
railroad station they build a tall
wooden fence there and the nobody was
permitted to approach the fence the word
was out that they had machine guns lined
up alongside the fence in the street
which paralleled the railroad tracks but
even then you see I was not so much
afraid of the machine guns as you know
my discipline you know I did not have
permission to sneak up on the railroad
station I had permission to go and get
something from the city by something but
I sneaked up to the fence and I was in
my cast sock so I really stood out there
because I looked left and right but I
didn't say anything anybody even
soldiers so and I found a hole there it
was a raw wood fence and that was the
day when I saw my training the potty
train and it just must have pulled into
the station that I see very with great
clarity no difficulty to recall at all
colors everything it was a cattle train
and right in front of me just about two
tracks from the
fence stood one of the wagons and I
could see some more because the hole was
large and it was just opened it was
opened by an SS soldier that I noticed
those were already German soldiers I
didn't see Hungarians there and it was
the impression was terrible because it
was terribly packed I literally saw what
you see in pictures mothers with
children and people and old people and
little children and all the impression
was terrifying it was really packed
I mean compressed and one man
immediately jumped off and I always
remembered his face because he looked a
little bit like my father and he must
have been something like mid-40s closing
on 150 I did not hear what he said to
the German soldier to that SS soldier
but his behavior was polite he jumped
off and my feeling was my instinct or
what I'm a dad that he was asking for
water and immediately that SS soldier
with the club of his rifle clubbed him
down and several times I - in sensivity
whether he died or whether he was later
put on the track and then I heard anyway
I was so scared and I was so upset I
never saw anything like this in my life
I simply ran away and you know this I
see it personally is the greatest energy
of my life that you know there Jewish
people were deported or on me I didn't
do anything
I panicked I'm not even medic not even
fear I just didn't know what to do now
my second direct experience was
the crying in the night it was
summertime and it was one of those very
very quiet nights and I could not sleep
for some reason and there was enough
moisture in the air we were quite far
from the railroad station but somehow
there must have been enough moisture to
carry sand and I woke up to the sound of
many people my impression was literally
thousands of people crying I didn't know
what it was first it was it was a
terrifying impression and then I
realized this is the sound of people
crying I remember even reflecting you
know that must be children women men
everybody because it was that kind of a
chorus wailing and crying and next
morning I talked to the several other
people were still left in the in the
Jesuit house and asked them if they
heard something our housekeeper
custodian and they all said that they
heard it and I think it was the
custodian a gardener janitor who told me
that those were the Jewish people crying
because at our station the Hungarians
and armory handed them over to the SS
troops to be deported to Germany and
sometimes when this happened
the people would start to cry and that
would spread to a full train and this is
what we heard that night I didn't know
about the death camps as such at that
time and I didn't know about the ovens
the burning
but I personally at that moment I felt
persuasion coming up on me that these
people will be all killed and again you
see this is where I stress what I am
trying to say I wish I could live my
life today maybe I would be ready to
them run in front of the train and lay
down and I don't want to sound dramatic
maybe I would have today I would call
out or protest or risk being shot down
or club down and at that time I was
immobilized it was just a feeling not or
even a feeling of what can I do there is
nothing to do just running away simply
nothing away it was it was beyond my
experience I was utterly badly bad I
remember waking up on a Saturday morning
I heard shots again I quickly ran to my
window that was my my observation point
like my my eyes must have been three
times as big this as they are now
because I remember spending lots of
hours in that window
I ran to it and I looked around and I
saw dead people all around and on the
square about an hour later I heard
German voices
raus raus raus that was one word that I
learned very quickly I meant out out our
to us was like a door like dogs barking
and
they were German voices telling
everybody all Jews out all Jews out of
the square we heard people beginning to
cry and chaos where everybody was
running up and down in my building my
cousin finally started yelling to my
family and whoever because people
started running into the hiding place
and out nobody knew what fight what to
do some of us who got into the hiding
place
my cousin finally shut the door and said
all right now you're in and nobody out I
myself started crying and I said I
wanted to go with everybody else my dad
also wanted to go but he closed the door
he closed the little door underneath and
he said nobody's moving out of here as a
matter of fact he I remember him saying
distinctly he said if you're going to
die you gotta die right here you're not
going to walk to you death I started
crying and but then he made me shut up
and then I looked out through there was
the only opening for for air was there
was like a porthole here under the roof
and I looked out and I saw lots of Jews
with little packages walking towards the
square and I also saw my grandfather my
other grandfather Matt from my father's
side who lived in a different building
and his room and my grandma coming over
and they were looking up and deciding
whether to come to come up and hide with
us or to go away and finally I saw the
mark again walk away and I never saw
them again
I heard I heard people yelling and
screaming and crying and shooting and a
hoedown so but when we went to my donek
this was just the most terrible as much
as I experienced bad things after but
this was they put us in cattle cars and
they pushed in I don't know how many
people but they really wanted us to die
and we warned us those wagons um I don't
know how many people were there but my
daughter died in my arms
my younger brother was
and my husband's two sisters it's not
enough oxygen folders people and they
kept us in the swag ins for days they
wanted us to die in the wagons you know
the kettle class with very little
windows how old was your brother maybe
13
he wasn't about my family so you know
when my mother died my nerves and said
to myself I ain't gonna live I must be
the only one survivor for my family I'm
gonna live
I made up my mind I'm gonna defy you I'm
not gonna give it because he wants me to
die I'm gonna live I'm going to just be
very very strong and this is something
really nightmarish
when we came to that camp I can probably
describe something for somebody who
hasn't seen it
but has seen the film the apocalypse now
we came at night and were surrounded by
a group of people with yellow faces
begging for scraps of bread covered with
blankets
and typical muscle man's
as we found out the following day work
see
was fabricating the chemicals name EP
clean to fill the shelves
this is the explosive thing that
explodes in their artillery shells and
working with that chemical your lifespan
is only three four months your skin
turns yellow you shrivel and this will
be patron airs surrounding us
ouch wits if I would like to describe it
I would say that is there has not been
that has not been people did not invent
an expression what ash which was it was
hell on earth and
the silence of Auschwitz was held
the nights were hell
and the day's somehow we got up at 3 o
clock in the morning and at 4 o'clock
summer time or 4:30 when the Sun came up
it was not like the Sun I swear to you
it was not bright
it was always read to me it was always
black to me it never said never never
was life to me it was destruction the
Sun was never beautiful and when the
moon was out it meant only destruction
we almost forgot what life was all about